(Brady: When you think about the constraints on a sudoku
grid, and I- obviously there's the famous one, you've)
(got to have 1 to 9 in these rows, columns.
But this is another constraint on a sudoku. It's)
(amazing that so many are possible, it's amazing
they can make so many different ones.)
- Oh yeah
the the world of sudoku um it's almost a sort of
bottomless pit. We've just done the Phistomafel
ring and we saw how sets of different digits can
be important. I'm going to show you something mad
now which is where sudoku constructors have taken
this sort of thinking. I don't know if you can see
this this grid here, but there's a few things
to know about the the rules of sudoku as they
apply in this grid. So you can see there are
some cages in the grid; so the digits in this
cage have to sum to Y to the power of 2, the
digits in this cage have to sum to X to the power 2.
And the only other thing you really need to
know is that these- see these arrows with circles?
The digits along the arrow have to sum up to
the digit in the circle. So if this was a 1 and
this was a 2, this would be equal to 3. This
puzzle involved trying to work out what X and Y
were; and using the Phistomafel ring and the ideas
of set theory you can work it out. And that's what
I'll try and show you now.
- (It also has to obey
the normal sudoku rules of the columns, the rows)
(and the squares?)
- Yes it does, it does indeed. Let me
start: so this time we're going to highlight the
first four rows of the grid using the red pen. And
again we know that the the red cells are four sets
of the digits 1 to 9 altogether. And now our green
cells this time are not going to be quite the
same. So we- I'm going to highlight five complete
columns. So in this instance we've got four sets
of the digits 1 to 9 in the red cells, and five sets
of the digits 1 to 9 in the green columns. And we
can see if we look carefully again - let's use my
blue pen - this portion of the grid has two colours
in every cell. So we can remove all of these from
both sets and we know that the difference between
the red set of tiles and the green set of tiles
is still one set of the digits 1 to 9; because we
had four sets versus five sets, we've removed the
same thing from both, so the difference is still
one set of the digits 1 to 9. I want to imagine
the we remove this box 1, this box here, from
the red set. So now what's the difference between
the red tiles we've got remaining and the green
tiles we've got remaining is now two sets of the
digits 1 to 9. So we're going into mad mad lands
now. But we can actually use this to solve this
puzzle; because what we've got remaining in red is
just this cage which we know sums to Y to the power of2. And what we've got left in the bottom of the
grid is all all of those squares. So it's all of
these squares versus this cage, the difference is
two sets of the digits 1 to 9. And this is where
constructors get even more crazy, because they
say okay well what would happen if we equalised
those differences? So what we could do is add the
whole of column 9 into red. And what we could do is
add the whole of row 9 into red. And if we did
that - this cell is obviously twice in red now this
cell here - but if we do that red and green are now
equivalent again, because we've added one complete
set- one more complete set of red into into the
red set and another complete row of the sudoku
that's another complete set of the digits 1 to 9
into the red set. So at the moment the red and the
green are now equivalent. And now you can play some
games to isolate this cage, which I- hopefully you
can see is X to the power of 2. And the way that you
do that is you take out, just as we did before, you
take out the cells from both that are common
which is this one, this one, this one, this one, this
one, this one, this one, and this one. And if you look
very carefully now you can see that these arrows
which have to add up to the same number, these two
digits here sum up to the same as a digit in the
green set. So if we were to take these two digits
out of red and take this digit out of green, the
sets still should sum to the same number. We can
take these two out and knock this one out. And
look at the what we're left in the corner, we've
got this cell here which was twice in red and
once in green; so if we cancel that once from
red and once from green we end up with it being
once in red. And it cancels out with its arrow
here like that, and we now have an equation where
we have proved that what is left in red is exactly
equal to what is left in green. And this is the
difference of squares, because you can see that
x^2 is equal to y^2 + x + y from these cages.
And that allows you if- you you can solve that
equation and you'll find out that X and Y differ
by exactly 1 and that allows you to solve the
puzzle.
- (Simple)
- Not simple, but actually
once you start to understand Phistomafel-
achievable and quite magical. And the thing I
really love about this puzzle is the puzzle
title was 'difference of squares' and it results
in a mathematical difference of squares being
the equation but that equation is derived from
what we did at the start, which was to find the
different- the geometric difference of squares
in the grid. So sort of the title is hinting at
the geometry and hinting at the maths involved.
It's really beautiful.
- (Simon, did the person who)
(set this puzzle realise this was the way it
could be solved? Or was there other- other waysto do it?)
Yeah this was set by mathguy_12 uh who
is a mathematician. I think they're doing
a PhD in number theory and they wanted to set
a puzzle that could explain to a layman about
the difference of squares. And they achieved it in
this sort of magic magical way. It's the first
puzzle I believe they've ever set, so it's it's
quite an incredible debut.
- (You couldn't- but you)
(couldn't solve this like people on the train
by putting - does a 1 work there? Does a 2-)
No. I invite you to try. I think- I
don't think you could get through it. You maybe
if you gave yourself a hundred years and youguessed a lot you could do it by iteration butit wouldn't be fun.
If you haven't already seen
it, I'll include a link below to our video with
Simon about the mysterious Phistomafel ring. There'll
also be links to Simon and his mate Mark's
...take all the possible sudoku grids and
check all of them for 16 clue starting
positions; and to check if they give you
a unique answer. That's that's one way to
do it, it's a brute force way to do it. How many
ways are there to pick 16 clues from my sudoku grid?